all right from uh thwarting democracy at
home to scowling at it abroad you can
always count on the american left to
stand with the dictators at least if
they're anti-american
upon fidel castro's death jimmy carter
remarked that he and rosalind remembered
fondly their visits with him in cuba
and his love of his country obama
continued that democratic tradition
attending a baseball game with raul
extolling cuba's
achievements in education and health
care
and the media even gets in the game you
know who could forget barbara walters
fawning 2020 interview with castro that
was a classic
so it should come as no surprise that
with the democratic protests spilling
out this weekend
the media well they look for a cuban
scapegoat
there's no question that the pandemic
has made everything
uh much worse people there are outraged
over the country's coronavirus response
their life has become intolerable during
the pandemic
but the new york times might have had
the best reaction writing that the
protests were
were shouting freedom and other
anti-government slogans something tells
me
the times was just being honest about
where they stood joining me now former
secretary of state fox news contributor
mike pompeo um secretary pompeo the
reaction
from the media uh the democrats the left
um has been i think quite revealing
to people who've forgotten that they
were doing the same kind of thing
you know with the soviet union back in
the 80s when i was in college
yes laura thanks for having me on the
show it's absolutely the case
they've pointed the finger kova they've
the cubans have pointed the
finger at the americans the truth is
this is about communism this is about
socialism this is about people demanding
freedom they know
that the lives of their families won't
be better next generation
they know that their country is was
designated by me as a state sponsor of
terror
they know that things aren't good the
conditions of the of the evil
leadership and the communist dictates of
that leadership have
have spoiled their lives and they want
freedom you see them waving not only
cuban flags but american flags
these are people who understand and you
if you've seen anybody down in florida
who left cuba those exiles that are
now living in america they know freedom
they know the reality of it they know
the benefits of it they know why it
matters to their
soul and their pocketbook it's all the
cuban people are asking for this isn't
about the coronavirus this isn't about
an american plot this is about the cuban
people demanding that their leadership
fundamentally change their ways
but mr secretary they did kind of the
same thing did they not
during the hong kong protest there was a
very
muted reaction uh by the elites here in
the united states
obviously we we pointed out what the
sports community was doing
uh which was thwarting real support
of what was happening in hong kong but
that that's a huge issue there now
this is not really surprising is it to
anyone who's seen what they've done over
the years
not at all laura it is the case that the
left is always cozied up to marxism
communists right they've always played
ftse with them they haven't seen the
evil that's perpetrated by them
they slough it off sometimes they'll
even go so far as to say boy that system
works pretty good right this is what
they said about the chinese communist
party they said
wow they handled kovad really well we we
know what communism does to countries we
know what it does to the souls of people
i don't understand why the democrats are
silent on this today
this is an important opportunity for the
cuban people the american people need to
stand alongside them there are so many
things we can do
to help them gain this very freedom that
they're on the streets demanding it
at enormous personal risk we need to be
with the cuban people the trump
administration had the right end of the
stick
we put enormous pressure on the cuban
leadership i hope the biden team
won't release the pressure that we had
on the cuban leadership
that pressure plus the freedom demands
of these people is likely to lead to a
really good outcome for cuba
and as a result a really good outcome
for the secure security of america as
well
but mr uh mr secretary isn't it the case
that this administration thinks
conservatives in the united states who
like wave the american flag
not on memorial day or fourth of july
but you know fly it all the time or
heaven forbid off a
boat or something they're the bigger
threat to the united states
do their domestic terrorists are
approaching that much bigger threat than
a communist you know dictatorship in
cuba or maybe even china
at this point i mean look at the effort
they're putting into
january 6 i mean if only they put that
effort into you know changing things in
cuba
the irony there laura is that they often
say that they're that the team that
loves human rights and yet we can see
the human rights that are being violated
there
and we know we know these same people
would love nothing more than to come to
the united states of america the same
place that these
democrats are denigrating that very flag
that they are denigrating is the very
flag that the cuban people so
desperately want to have on their side
it shouldn't escape us this hypocrisy
it is dangerous when the democrats
undermine our republic
we can do better i'm confident the
american people can see that
and if we get this right we'll improve
the rights of people all across the
world
and america will be safer and more
secure all right i'm rooting for the
cuban people today you bet great people
and white house press secretary jen
sake secretary pompeo she seemed
a bit stumped by truth be told a very
difficult question
watch does the administration support
international protesters flying the
american flag
the president certainly values and
respects
the the uh symbol symbol of
the american flag he's someone who uh
certainly uh
waves it outside of his uh house or ha
does in delaware and
and other places where he's lived
throughout his time but he also believes
that people have the right to peaceful
protests and he thinks both can be true
how difficult is it just to say the
american flag is the greatest symbol of
freedom on earth i mean
that seems like it's hard for them to to
say that
it's really straightforward and pretty
darn simple and when you see
her dance around in that way you could
tell she's nervous about answering a
question
about what he's nervous about asking a
question about the american flag
the other tell laura is that when when
folks denigrate our flag
and diminish america that it won't call
out uh their own team right they won't
call out bernie sanders when he says no
cuba's a great place that's a great
health care system won't call out
aoc or the squad when they undermine
american values
that's a real tell it means that they
are uncomfortable
at best and they might mouth the right
words for a moment but they're not going
to defend it with all the glory that it
deserves
mr secretary thanks for being with us
tonight and